ich habe meine hand spucke hatte mein
name ist herzlich willkommen wir heute
einen neuen video von ich bin nicht
alleine sondern mit weich gemacht und
wir haben heute wissen und so eine
kleine papa aufgeklebt und zwar machen
wir eine challenge die aircraft berlin
engeln weg haben auf jeden fall ist eine
challenge bei der sie beispielsweise in
eine sache liegen haben in diesem fall
ein iphone oder mit markt waren okay ich
glaube ihnen dann erläutert 100 und ich
glaube halt nicht und dann lösen wir das
auch und wenn er verdrängte damit
ehrenpunkt und wenn er falsch lag ich im
punkt und lockert das prinzip verstanden
der gewinner leute kriegt 5000 gleich ja
ich würde sagen dass ich hier auf meinen
kanal dazu anfangen mit dem ersten
gegenstand ich halte in meiner hand eine
familie üben ich würde sagen du hast das
spaghettiessen beantworten
man habe aus was seine erste sachen
altmeisters artikel mitgebracht habe ist
eine dunkelblaue boxershort horrenden
kannst du mitgebracht haben und kannst
kann ich mir mein mann und ich stinke
setzt man manchmal in richtung befährt
psychologie des sektors
[Applaus]
an einem frühen rückschlag da ich würde
sagen da ist das auffällig gekaperte und
beweist hat mich erst mitte und jetzt
aus der detailliert beschrieben
meine gegenstand in einem bild von mir
und fällt bei der premiere vor gering
weiß was existiert aber ich meine dass
die welt ein lobbyist das sagen damit
gehört definitiv nicht an da hat kommt
er findet aber also ich kann das besser
es geht etwas freizeit haben für alle
sich tierarten die teife in meiner hand
über luca eine rolle klopapier ich meine
eigentlich bei der letzten auftritte
waren die letzten oktober für die
toilette angebracht habe aber ich würde
sagen stimmt ja geholt auf einer tafel
welt wir wollen ja zusammen
dabei habt ihr auf zwei top dogs sehr
sehr schwierig und möglichst schnell
die touchscreen man hört dass der glaube
keine der gewinner ell ich kann meine
hand lieber luca ein vorhängeschloss mit
schlüssel ja nicht ob du hatte
versammelte sich heiße in meinen händen
in der hand zwei top blogger ja ja
wasser fiel
er studiert hier so viel ich möchte
meine hand eine entwerfe ich habe gerade
als eine was hier aufgebaut
die angefertigten videos direkt neben
der tür
ich will mich aber durch dich und behüte
auswählen wird keine sickere
wie kann jetzt nur noch ausgleichen das
heißt ich muss mich jetzt auch täuschen
ich habe meine hand spucke unentschieden
mittwoch eine runde schwächen machen wir
wieder in meiner hand ein
und ich glaube hier eine art wenn ich
jetzt immer war
wie muss man ich heute in meiner hand
genau die gleiche ob das schon die
gerade wenn unternehmen oder auch fiktiv
ich habe natürlich das stativ wurde ich
bin ein unentschieden alter gefallen hat
was gerne mal weiter wir haben beim
macht genau das gleiche aufgenommen das
ist wird auch online gegangen das heißt
und in der beschreibung von ihnen das
video 45 gelegen wo gerade noch mag eine
eingeblendete werden könnte main kanal
abonnieren und dort findet ihr auch eine
weiteres video eingeblendet video
klicken